everybody knows about placebos right
they're only discovered in World War II
and it was discovered by accident this
doctor ran out of morphine and he's
treating these these people that are
badly injured and you know you need the
morphine not just so they're out of pain
but so they don't go into shock and the
actual person who discovered this gets
no credit was a nurse because the nurse
hand him a syringe and said we've got
some more morphine so he believed it and
he said you'll be out of pain in just
less than a minute he injected them and
in every case none of them went into
shock ninety percent of them were out of
pain and they used nothing it was saline
right so after World War II he went back
to Harvard and he was the person that
created what we now considered being the
double bind studies which are always
compared to a placebo right and what
most people don't know is the bigger the
placebo intervention the more powerful
the Mind believes it so a small pill is
less effective than a big pill an
injection is more powerful than a pill
in terms of its Effectiveness the most
powerful is a is a sham surgery the
Veterans Administration did a study and
they did it on people doing knee
surgeries and they took one third of the
people and they just cut them open you
mysticize them and so the backup did
nothing A year later this group the
group that had no surgery had the least
amount of pain the most amount of
flexibility until they stopped funding
those surgeries but that's how powerful
it is it's even more than Harvard did a
study where they took barbiturates
babies big red pills and said this is an
amphetamine you need to prepare your
body because you're going to speed up it
didn't give him something fake they give
him an actual drug that slows the body
down and the body sped up so most people
understand the power of the mind and so
what I try to do is show people even in
this book here are the things that you
can do to take control of your mind
because if you take care of your body
and then you don't take care of your
mind and emotions you can be miserable
need motivation what's your top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carl
Michael and I make these videos because
you are probably the most ambitious
person in your circle but you know
you're capable of more and you get that
Push by surrounding yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best Tony Robbins and my take on his
top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two Chase joy and happiness
41 years of my life I've been obsessed
with trying to find the ways to help
people having a greater quality of life
whatever that is for them life on their
terms not my idea of what a quality life
is but theirs and you know people come
to me all the time and come to events
and they want to transform their
business or they want to transform their
body or they want to rebuild or deepen a
relationship or create one or they just
want to feel Joy or happiness we're all
pursuing all these things but really
it's just this experience of life life
at its highest level that we're all
searching for and over the last few
decades you know early in my life I
figured I didn't have much control of my
external World there was so much
suffering that I figured I gotta master
that and so I worked hard and for
decades learning from the smartest
people I could how could I achieve
succeed breakthrough master myself push
myself and all those tools you could
call maybe the science of achievement
it's like how do you take what you
envision and make it real how do you go
from you know having possibility to
actually creating that in your life but
as I've experienced that over the
decades I also noticed that so many
people who are great Achievers were just
not happy I mean I go to India I usually
go about every 12 to 18 months and I
remember when I first went there I was
like this poverty was overwhelming to me
and it was so confusing to see people so
happy you know because all around them
they seem to have such squalor I'd see
if someone's sitting in the street and
there was just so much joy in their eyes
if you took the time to feel them and
talk with them instead of judging the
environment and then I'd come home to
the United States where there's all this
external abundance and you'd find people
you know many of you know I wrote money
Master the gambling 50 of the smartest
Financial people in the world self-made
billionaires and not I wouldn't say the
majority of them are really happy and it
has nothing to do with the money it's
that the internal world was not mastered
so if there's two Sciences or two Master
skills I think in life that we wanted so
if we took east and west and put them
together and we didn't make the other
one wrong we'd say hey it's mastering
the science of achievement but also the
art of fulfillment and of the two for
the last four or five years I've been
traveling the country really trying
people to get people to feel and
experience the beauty that comes when
what's inside is great regardless of
what's outside the outside world ever
make you happy long term what you get
will never make you happy who you become
what you experience what you give that's
what makes us really happy rule number
three discover New Perspectives a lot of
the generation that you see today you
know the you know Z generation not so
much because they're just coming up
right but the millennial generation my
older people they see them as weak you
know they're snowflakes or this and
they're that but they have technology
they have insights and when the outside
world is demanding enough not yet
because they're still fearful
they will grow and that's when things
change and so the season occurs so think
about the difference between the 30s and
the 40s
versus the 50s
versus the 60s as we came after 63 into
an American Summer is a different
mindset versus the 80s to the 2000s 2000
does so we're right now halfway through
winter
we're in another winter it starts
financially now it's gone to health but
we're far from it it's going to be war
and it might be cyber War might be full
on war but there's zero question that
China and the U.S are in a collision
course that's going to shape the
direction of humanity and so the people
that right now are alive today are going
to have to grow in that environment I
really think we're at a season where
there's going to be a whole new level of
growth and what I just want to do is be
one of them any sources that can give
people perspective because here's the
problem
a year ago people thought we were coming
out of you know got vaccines now and
we're coming out of covid and it's going
to be all over now and people are
excited
but now after going through two years of
this
there's a lot of people now that no
longer have a compelling future like you
know people talking about New Year's
resolutions most people don't even have
one because it's like they never
followed through anyway right but at
least they had something to look forward
to they're starting to get a learned
helplessness learn helplessness
something is so bad over and over again
you start thinking the problem's
permanent no problem is permanent or you
start thinking the problem is pervasive
because I haven't handled my finances my
whole world's over because my
relationship's bad The Whole World's
over your life is bigger than that or
all this is happening because there's
something wrong with me when you get to
that point you stop trying and so my
goal right now is to shake that up for
people people need a new perspective and
you can't do it by just sitting and
thinking you've got to move your body
you got to change your energy and your
focus because low level of energy I
don't think I'm a gamble how smart you
are you're not going to use all your
ability but if I get you into a higher
state of being mentally emotionally
physically and all of a sudden you start
remembering who you are and you start
coming up with answers that you never
even thought were possible before rule
number four find what drives you I think
most people who are driven have drive
already it's really about directing that
drive it's really about strategy
um but I do believe in passion I do
believe in energy because without high
levels energy you don't do anything but
most of my focus is really how increase
the quality of life for people and I've
basically spent my life studying who are
the most successful people on Earth in
various areas your body your emotion
your relationship your finances you know
your business and I've tried to apply
those things to myself first to prove
they work to me and then I've been able
to take them to tens of millions and
hundreds of millions of people people
through events and programs and I love
to do it in a way that actually creates
change you know Harvard did a excuse me
Stanford did a study they came to me
during covid because as you know uh you
know people of depressions shot through
the roof as people were shut down we've
had the largest number of people
overdose on drugs in our entire history
as a country and you know if you go
traditionally to deal with depression
how do you do it well you maybe go to a
therapist and they work very hard to
help you and more than likely they give
you a medication and you know Across The
Meta studies they explained to me at
Stanford that only about 40 of people
actually are helped 60 after a year have
not improved at all the 40 that do
improve you go across all the meta
studies the average Improvement is about
50 percent they're half as depressed as
they were now some people are totally
cured and some people not at all of
course but it's pretty pathetic when you
think about it because placebos can
almost have that impact and so they came
to me and they said you know Tony they
some of the people from the Stanford
genetics lab actually attended My Date
With Destiny seminar it's a six day
total immersion program where you
basically find out your brain creates
meaning how you value things how to
shift that and they were radically
shifted when was very depressed so he
said there's no real data would you be
willing to do a study on how using no
drugs what kind of impact we could find
so they took a group of people and they
they did a group they modeled the the
most successful study ever Dan was done
recently two years ago I think was it
John Hopkins that you're still a Simon
which is basically magic mushrooms and
and therapy for a month and they produce
result unlike anything I've ever seen 53
of the people after 30 days were no
longer had no symptoms whatsoever being
depressed which it's like four times
more than you would normally see and so
um but unfortunately it's an illegal
drug and they're still trying to figure
out how to utilize it so they wanted to
use this event so they put one group and
they mirrored them they had a group do
positive journaling from Stanford and
then the group that went through the
seminar and they're about 17 percent had
um idea to focus on suicide the rest
were depressed clinically depressed and
after 30 days this is the part they
couldn't believe they literally uh
double blinded this twice by two other
organizations because they just couldn't
believe it 100 of the people were
absolutely free of any symptoms and none
of them had idiotic Suicidal Thoughts at
the end of 30 days then they just
studied following people 11 months later
from the general population who went to
one of my programs digitally for four
days just the weekend it's called
Unleash the Power then and they found 70
reduction in negative emotions 52
percent increase in positive emotions 48
crop and anxiety but 11 months later
they still have the same numbers and it
was still covered that's why the 11
versus 12 months so there are tools out
there that can make a difference and so
to think that's motivation certainly
knowing what drives you is important if
you're overweight what drives you is
food right you know let's be honest
everyone's driven the question is about
what are you driven to relax are you
driven to change the world are you
driven to get healthy and so my focus
has really been finding those strategies
and I'm really excited I've been doing
this for this is my you know 45th year
doing this I started when I was 17
believe it or not I'm 62 and I've seen
just about how many you can imagine in
195 countries working with people and
you discover that it's just patterns
like you have extraordinary patterns not
blowing smoke you and I are good friends
but I was blown away by you as a man not
only as a leader but as a human being
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five use pain to grow
why is it that we often wait to
experience pain before we decide to
change a part of our Lives make a
different choice to create a shift why
is it that we wait so often for stress
and pressure that question was burning
at me because you know I was traveling
around I have the privilege of this
stage of life you know traveling around
the earth that's why people from every
Walk of Life right 100 plus countries
I've worked in and I'd see the same
problems even though you mean different
cultures like you know go to an Asian
culture it's not about the individual
it's about the group right but I'd still
see the same problems and then I got
obsessed with it like okay what what's
the common Human Experience because I'm
seeing the same problems even though
it's a different culture even those
different beliefs right and I began to
realize that there are certain human
needs and there are six that identify
that I've used ever since and it's
helped me understand and so one of those
needs is certainty and it's the base
human need certainty that you can avoid
pain and that you can be comfortable is
the most basic need it's a survival need
because if you have continuous pain
that's continuous damage continuous
damage equals Death right but what
happens for people is most people that
first basic need is where they live they
don't grow another need the second need
is uncertainty because ironically if
you're certain all the time you're bored
out of your mind if you're completely
uncertain you're kind of freaked out and
a balance is not it it's the ability to
use
for both worlds and then there's the
need for significance which is a big
part of our culture today thanks to
social media
um that need to feel special unique
important right it can be a very
positive emotion or need it can be very
negative depending upon how it's used
how it's directed and then there's the
need for connection and love which
everybody has and those four needs
everybody finds a way to meet if you
have to lie to yourself work 20 hour
days you're going to find certainty
somehow you're going to find where I
variety you're going to find some form
of significance some people do it by
tearing other people down some people do
it by working harder you know it's
different you're going to find some
level of at least connection if not love
but the final two what make people feel
alive which is growing everything in the
universe grows or dies and contributing
everything in the universe contributes
or it's eventually eliminated by
Evolution so those are the spiritual
needs growth and contribution where you
get Beyond yourself and I think that the
majority of us don't take moves because
of fear and fear is just uncertainty
it's that base need and when I go around
and I describe this in more detail and I
work with a big audience 15 20 000
people and I'll say have them do a set
of exercises and figure out where do
they get what triggers them to be
certain or uncertain what triggers them
a variety and so forth so they
understand that like everything I do is
to meet these needs but then I'm going
to say what are your top two not what
you think they should be not what you
want them to be what are they and 90 of
people in our culture are certainty and
significance or significance uncertainty
even though they really want love so
they have this route like if I can be
successful enough then I'll be worthy of
it or if I can just control it enough
and know it's that way but you can't
control love right and so most people
are they're trying to meet their needs
and are kind of a backwards way and I
think that that fear that uncertainty is
what keeps the most people from going
until they get enough pain and then that
pushes them through a threshold where
their needs aren't being met they gotta
change and unfortunately most people
wait till they have enough pain now I
that's not my preference rule number six
know when to quit I stayed in a
relationship for 20 years where I was
really not happy I made everybody else
happy which was my whole sacrifice there
and um the reason I did it was because I
grew up with four fathers right I swore
I'd never get a divorce so you know you
build these ideals I remember there's
certain things like I'd rather die than
that oh what a stupidest thing to say
but we developed these beliefs that once
they become an ideal they kind of have
they possess you and they take you over
so you got to be able to question
anything and so the answer your question
is yes there's a time to move on there's
a time to start something new there's a
time to learn the lesson that this
business or this relationship or this
experience is given you and make a move
because otherwise the real testers are
you growing like if you're in a
relationship you know it's a great
relationship if you're constantly
wanting to be better for the person you
love if you don't really give a [ __ ]
what they think that's not a good sign
right right I mean it just means there's
not the level of intimacy there's not
the level of connection you might have
been together forever but it's not where
it needs to be so it's like telling
yourself the truth I think is the
hardest thing for people and I think the
ideals get in the way of that true roof
meaning the things you've you know and
grandized in your mind to be absolute
but I think when it comes to a business
it's not an easy question when it comes
to an investment I don't and Investments
it's easy I don't move to a new
investment until I found a better one I
don't just get pulled by the next shiny
thing I really look and make sure it's
there when it comes to businesses
I'm pretty crazy I've stayed in
businesses way too long I should have
probably gotten out but I did it and
then sold it and it made a little money
but just it was my whole thing that I
don't quit so but I think there are
times when you have to adapt the
business to something new I mean if I
was still doing what I was doing two
years ago you know on the road doing
what I was doing I mean I would do 115
cities on average
um usually 12 to 16 countries I was on a
train playing a helicopter every two to
three days and I mean I don't mean and
no one would have ever stopped me
because they couldn't because there's so
much momentum of what I'm doing but if I
was doing that right now you know my 250
employees at that company would be all
unemployed you know because all around
the world it made it illegal to do what
I was doing so you have to be able to
tell yourself the truth about where you
are and also they'll not give up too
easily by saying where's the season of
this business okay where's the
development like if a business is really
young it's a toddler business it's gonna
burn more cash then it's going to give
you back if it's a you know if it's a
business that's in that GoGo phase that
teenage phase you get overconfident
grows like crazy and then you don't have
the profits at some point on the sales
slow down and you got real trouble is it
a business that's aging but also I gotta
look at what's the industry like I'll
give an example I have a friend really
good guy maybe 44 45 years old Prime of
his life like you add really well put
together I mean takes care of his body
great mind great mindset without giving
his personal life away he owns a very
large business in Australia dominates an
industry
and the industry relates to big box
office supplies okay so I had them at
one of my business seminars and I'm
walking him through these stages just
like a human being goes through life
stages so does a business just like
history right yes if you know what stage
you're in you know you can do the right
thing at the wrong time and you don't
get rewarded yes rant in the winter you
don't get rewarded right buy a house
sounds good 2007. maybe not the best
time right you know so it's like you got
to take a look at where these things fit
where is the where is the real decision
making here that makes this happen so
anyway he's got this off supply business
and he's young and dynamic so in his
life cycle he's in his prime
yeah his business is in its Pride he's
worked for years it's crushing it
but where's the industry is that a young
business a growing business
an aging business and there's no
question it's an aging business and I
said to him I said you got to separate
these out because if you're using your
brain intelligently you got to sell this
business because even though you got a
great business the multiple is going to
go down every year because the
industry's going down yes you take those
resources and reinvest so again it's
looking at things by telling yourself
the truth seeing what stage they're in
and seeing what stage the world's in but
you might have the best idea in the
world but it's not going to work when
everybody's shed in their homes perhaps
think about what the product or service
is so you have to adapt rule number
seven be grateful if you're obsessed you
know what you want you're taking Massive
Action maybe you modeled somebody figure
out the right action so you get there
quicker and you're executing you still
need a little Grace
some people call it luck you could call
God but I really believe that there's
the part we do and then there's the part
that comes to us but I do know Grace
shows up a lot more when you do the
first two steps on your own and Grace
shows up a lot more when you acknowledge
Grace in your life when you acknowledge
that I was born in a world where I
didn't have to build this internet that
I can pull out of my pocket to answer
anything on Earth I'm driving on streets
I didn't pave I'm reading books I didn't
have to write that's the gift of our
lives and I think when we experience
that Grace we don't just experience more
achievement but we start to experience
more fulfillment and Grace not only
affects your ability to get there but it
affects what you do and how you you live
once you are there it really determines
the quality of your life because unless
you live in a state of gratitude you
know I I did an interview with Sir John
Templeton who as you know is one of the
first billionaire investors and just a
brilliant man he came from nothing and
he donated I think it was 750 they still
do it the Templeton fund I think it's
750 million dollars a year it's bigger
than a Nobel fund that he donates and
one day I asked them I said what is the
secret to wealth and he looked at me
pause this big smile and his eyes got
really bright like they always did and
he said Tony it's what you teach I said
well I teach a lot of things you know
which thing and he said gratitude he
said because you and I Tony know
billionaires that are miserable and it's
because they're not grateful for what
they have and we both know people have
no money seemingly but they're so
grateful for their health for their
husband for their wife for their
children they're so grateful that God
they're so grateful for their life that
they're rich you know so I think I think
it starts with that gratitude it starts
with that connection to Grace as
simplistic as that sounds and so it's
not enough just to have your financial
plan you have all the money and be
miserable let's have the money and be
really rich emotionally psychologically
and spiritually rule number eight be
persistent disappointment either
destroys you or drives you and you have
to decide which one it's going to be if
you don't consciously decide there's
always going to be more BS for you to
deal with and I think but that's why I
think you know when I do my events the
reason I do the 12 hours a day it's not
because I like talking it's just that I
can tell you something all day long or I
can get you to build the muscle yes and
the building muscle is by experiencing
and I always tell people a belief I
believe it's a poor substitute for an
experience like I could have a belief
about you and I experience you so I get
to know who you are right the same
thing's true is like you have a belief
about China you have a belief about
working out so I try to give people
experiences that are so profound and
then you know the the studies they did
they found people 12 months later 11
months later we're still in the middle
of covet they did my digital seminar and
you know they measured my body like the
amount of times I jump I jump a thousand
times a day and I weigh 282 pounds and I
come down four times the body weight so
it's a thousand pounds times a thousand
pounds of pressure my lactic acid if
you've ever been with a friend and
you're running and you can't talk the
point you can't talk is the level four
of lactic acid I'm in an 18 and still
speaking so they decided to do that on
my audience
and they found an interesting pattern
it's the same group that works with some
of the you know Super Bowl champions and
some of the Stanley Cup champions and so
forth there's a ratio in the body of
testosterone versus cortisol the stress
hormone and when the ratio is balanced
they call it the championship bloodline
by our bloodstream it literally gets you
to follow through so when they did my
audience in my live seminar they found
that people literally mirror me all the
way through the experience that's
phenomenal biochemically that is
phenomenal but what we did it on we did
it you know because all of a sudden
overnight they said to me you know we're
going to San Francisco and the governor
of California says you can only have 10
people
and we got 15 000 so I was like We'll go
to Vegas they'll never shut down Vegas
they shut down Vegas I was like okay
we'll do 1500 movie theaters with 10
people in him they shut down the movie
theaters like okay we'll go to a church
in Houston I got a buddy I'll rent his
church for 10 15 000 people they're not
gonna keep Costco open and shut down the
church they kept Costco open and shut
down the church so I finally said okay
I'm not gonna do some crappy little
webinar so I get this Vision I'm gonna
build this facility with 20 foot high
LED screens 50 feet wide all around me
I'm gonna call Eric Young at Zoom I'm
gonna get them from a thousand up to 25
000 people so I could interact with
people live in real time on a build an
app so they can shake it and the more
people do it the louder it gets so it's
real so I built this whole thing so now
we're doing bigger events than ever in
our entire history but they did the same
measurements on them in different parts
of the world and saw the exact same
mirroring process and the average person
even digitally even the smartphone ever
yeah um 71 of the people they had 71
drop in negative emotions 53 Improvement
lots of emotions and 11 months later in
the middle of covid it helped because
it's a biochemical change so when people
say oh I'm trying that's I write books
because it it's an easy entry point to
people there's so much you can learn
from a book but there's nothing like the
experience that's why I do the events
and like these last two years because of
covet I did two like six day free events
we had 800 000 people at 10 for six days
just four weeks ago because I just
wanted people to have answers where they
are and then people start to see they
get momentum but it's hard to do just
reading something or watching a couple
of you know you know 20 minute or 15
minute or five minute little pieces on
YouTube those are great they might
inspire you but a transformation
requires immersion it's like yes if you
ask the average person
did you study a foreign language in
school most people oh yeah High School
College speak it they don't but if you
turn around and you said okay what if
you want to learn Italian and I just
took you to Rome and dumped you off for
six weeks yeah with no teacher You're
Gonna Come Back six weeks later speaking
you know Italian so it's immersion and
if you want to master something I think
that's the thing most people don't do
they read a little bit they listen a bit
they dip in and out they don't go day
and night night and day in total
immersion in something that transforms
them and also something that makes them
push through their fears yes because in
the end it's the only thing that stops
everybody's got a story I didn't know
this person I don't have the resources
they have all the things they don't have
but if you're resourceful you can get
the money you can get the time you can
get the energy you can get anything you
want and you've got to get over your
fear to be resourceful so we do
experiences that are so physiologically
profound that those fears do not stop
you anymore yeah and that's what that's
how we get people to get you know 10
years later they're still transformed
from an experience that was one weekend
rule number nine defeat fear first of
all if you're concerned about covid
according to CDC and I have this in my
new book the number one you know issue
besides age obviously the number one
piece is being overweight right or obese
that is number one and just this week
CNN New York Times for the first time
two years later coming and saying you
can reduce your risk if you take care of
your body right do you know what number
two is according to the CDC fear
because when you get fearful it changes
your breathing your body temperature
your attention to your body all these
things can create a trigger of reactions
hormones in your body that make you
crazy so when I say fear is physical
here's what I mean fear physical by the
way so is courage emotions are physical
if you're really scared have you ever
been that point where you're like
freaked out about something and you
can't quite fully swallow or you get
that feeling in your gut certainly but
courage is also physical that's what
you're talking about like it's like I
train myself from a very young age that
the number one thing I had to do so I
would follow through on the things we're
talking about here is I had to have a
mind and body that were strong together
that every day I was going to do
something to strengthen my body even if
it was just 10 minutes or 15 minutes
something was going to shift me
physiologically to do that and so I you
know I get scared or I get frustrated
and I go on a run I go on a Sprint and I
wasn't in shape didn't matter I pushed
myself Beyond where it's comfortable if
I go lift weights and I push Beyond
where it's comfortable with and when you
do that everything in your nervous
system changes because all of a sudden
when You Face something and you push
behind on the comfort zone you get
stronger and stronger even a little bit
each day changes things something about
a courage that's not you're not afraid
because there'd be no need for courage
courage is your schedule but you do it
anyway yeah and so training your body
and you and I both do this right we
train intensely because we know this is
the resource through which my mind is
going to try to make decisions and then
the second thing is every day you gotta
feed your brain your mind because if you
don't crap is going in there
automatically we all know that right
yeah I mean today it's chasing you
because we all know the news knows
they're not bad people they're good
people they're just doing their job
their job is make sure they make as much
money for their shareholders and they
know one formula works and it's pretty
obvious these last two years more than
ever if it bleeds it leads if it
produces fear more people watch it's
because we all have a two million year
old brain that's always looking for
what's wrong what kind of hurt us but
your two million year old brain is not
going to make you happy right yeah you
have to take control of that two million
year old brain and start to direct
consciously what you want your life to
be so changing your body radically by a
workout by a run by Push by whatever
you're going to do shifting by feeding
your brain every single day and then
making sure every day you're taking some
form of action towards a compelling
future like what am I going to make
better if you have nothing to look
forward to you're going to be pissed off
you're going to be frustrated you're
going to be depressed you're going to be
overwhelmed and in those emotional
states even though you're a smart person
and you know lots of things you won't
use anything you know so to me the
leverage to changing somebody's life is
always starting with the human body if I
started to speak to you
and I spoke more at uh
this Tempo and I said yeah I really
think people should get their act
together and make this their best year
ever right
I feel terrible in my body now I'm not
saying everybody needs to talk fast or
loud like me that's my own physiology
but it's kind of train but everyone has
different gears and when you're low
gears like you can be in a great
relationship somebody you totally love
and you're both in a great physical
state emotional state everything's great
you both get a little love from taking
the kids to 20 soccer practices and
Casual problems in the business and all
that stuff and all of a sudden Same Love
doesn't feel like the same love you
still love each other but it doesn't
come across and if you're both stressed
out then it creates problems in the
relationship so the most important
factor in your life is the ability to
manage your mental emotional state is
the one thing you have complete control
of once you learn how then it becomes
just the daily discipline and after it's
not even discipline it just becomes
Habit to say I'm not going to live in
this lousy Pace I'm not going to put up
with it I know what to do let me do it
let me move forward but that's why you
know I do programs and events where I
immerse people yeah because you know you
and I can talk about this team and it's
kind of Nod your head but if I put you
in an experience correct I always tell
people a belief is a poor substitute for
an experience you can have a belief
about China I take you to China you're
going to have an experience it's very
different so I think human beings need
to put themselves more in experiences a
lot of us today especially with coven
being stuck at home and doing business
from home a lot of people are stuck in
their head yeah I tell you get in your
head you're dead you're just going
circles get in your head you got to get
that body and that energy moving and
then your head will start to work as
well angle number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is expand
your identity you're really talking
about the most important concept and
Lasting change identity
we all Define ourselves in certain ways
and most of us defined ourselves years
ago and we haven't done an update and
now you're in an environment where
you're constantly told how bad it is how
terrible it is so that stimulates the
old part of the human brain the
fight-or-flight mechanism the part of
your brain is always looking for what's
wrong so you can hide from it you know
or you can fight it or you can freeze
and hope it doesn't notice or you can
run from it and so that part of our
brain is never going to make you happy
it's an important part there's no
saber-toothed tiger for us to run from
anymore or fight right not for most
people but now we get that about what
are people saying about me online or you
know or do I have enough money in a
country that even if you have very
little money in America even if you're
in quote unquote a poor environment you
know I I support I provide 100 million
meals a year I've done I'm almost to a
billion meals now I'm at 825 million
meals to give you an idea in the last
seven years so I'm into helping everyone
possibly can but you got to help them
here and here too you know so I use the
food as the excuse to get into here and
here and start showing people what's
possible and I think we're in a place
right now where a lot of people are in
this learned helplessness and they don't
realize you know if you if if as an
identity if identity is how you've
identified yourself
and you see yourself as a procrastinator
why because you procrastinated so many
points and disappointed you don't want
to be disappointed so now you're a
procrastinator you're no longer
disappointed you feel certain you'll
never have your goals but you feel
certain that's what most people do in
their life but if you set let's say a
thermostat in this room at 78 degrees
and the temperature drops far enough
something's going to happen because the
computer's gonna go hey hey you're at 78
degree or what are you doing here at 68
and the heaters kick on and suddenly you
get this drive I'm sure your listeners
or viewers have had this experience many
times your life where Finance not
another day now I'm changing this
relationship I'm losing this waiter I'm
gonna finally do something and then you
push push push now some people push push
push and they go beyond their comfort
zone beyond what they expect not their
goals
it's what they're used to it's their
comfort zone and let's say that 68
degrees is where they're used to
financially it's not what they want or
their relationship or spiritually or
physically and they grow to 88 98 99
degrees certainly the brain goes hey hey
what are you doing here
you're you know you're you're not a 99
degree or
and then all of a sudden the heaters
stop and you lose your drive and if
that's not about the air conditioners
kick on you start to sabotage and you go
what happened to my life so identity is
the number one thing I work to change
with people to expand it not to get rid
of it but expand your own sense of who
you really are and what you're capable
of and people think they're going to get
identity by people say to me I have no
self-esteem I hate that word
so overused and abused I normally
self-esteem because when I was growing
up my parents said these terrible things
and those terrible things and I said
isn't it convenient you only remember
those things yes you know and they said
a million things but suddenly he was
holding on those but let's get real
someone can tell you your whole life
you're a piece of crap but you can say
screw you read between the lines and
make your life work
someone tell your whole life you're
beautiful you're intelligent you're the
smartest person in the world and you
don't believe it because self-esteem
doesn't come from what people say about
you self-esteem is earned within you
yourself it's esteem for yourself which
only comes by doing things that are
incredibly difficult and then your brain
goes this is who I am the reason I've
done firewalks for years I used to do
skydiving but you know it's hard to get
30 000 people in the middle of the Year
above New York in the middle of the
night but the reason I did these
metaphors was because when someone does
something they once thought was
difficult or impossible and they get the
other side of the brain goes if I get
myself to do this what else can I get
myself to do it changes their identity
when your identity expands your whole
world expands
momentum is everything right the hardest
part in life is creating momentum so
when that all happened you know I had
built something of momentum over you
know 40 years literally at that point
around the world and you know what do
you do all of a sudden when you know
suddenly they say you can't do an event
with more than 10 people and you've got
15 000 people scheduled to take over the
stadium and you know you know what I did
I went we're going to Vegas they're
never going to shut down Vegas right but
then they shut down Vegas I was like I
know I'm gonna rent a church a mega
church from a buddy of mine in Houston
15 000 people they're not going to keep
Costco open to shut down the church they
kept Costco open shut down the church so
I got to the point where it's like what
do you do and when you think there's
nothing you can do that's when you can
do something when you think I don't know
what to do that's when you know what to
do if you just push yourself and so I
was like I pulled my team together I saw
a guy do like a webinar with two 52-inch
screens and I said I'll kill myself
first I said I got to create an
experience for people they need it
desperately wherever they are in the
world so it's literally I pulled out of
tape recorders like okay here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna do 20 foot
high LED screen remains 50 feet wide
highest resolution in the world 0.67 150
you know 50 degree 180 degrees around me
around the back I'm going to call my
buddy Eric yon and I'm going to see if
Zoom we can expand him from the little
thousand to twenty thousand or thirty
thousand I'm gonna hire a firm to create
an app so they can shake it so it sends
a signal and you can hear reality of
people clapping because the more shake
it the louder it gets and I just started
creating the whole thing in an hour
there someone's done my my CFO says uh
Tony um you know after you saw all the
numbers there's over 20 million bucks by
the time we're done just like Tony uh
should we rent some of this first
and I said to him I said listen of all
first of all you can't I said go do your
best not what I'm looking for I said
second of all this is going to be this
way for a while yeah and we're going to
use this to help more people and that
wouldn't you know when things go back to
normal we get to go do that too and I
just did a date with Destiny where I had
you know uh 10 000 people from 97
countries and then I had 500 people in
front of me because I built the studio
so that there's 40 foot high ceiling so
I could literally lift the 20-foot
screen and so now I have a hybrid event
people don't want to come personally on
there people that want to be in the
middle of the night in some other
country are able to participate but all
that comes from just taking action and
momentum yeah if you build momentum you
can accomplish anything you've seen it
in sports you see a team that's
dominating and then somebody steals the
ball and the momentum changes yeah your
job right now is great momentum and
that's why I'm building this challenge
is basically to say to you let's do a
breakthrough for you right now so you
know it's real let's get you to get a
real result let's get you to shift
yourself physically and mentally and
emotionally so you can build that
momentum because it takes so much energy
to rock it out of the atmosphere takes
very little take it out of the solar
system so that momentum I think is
critical where focus goes energy flows
most people are focused on what they're
afraid of and so more fear comes their
way and it's easy because we all have a
two million year old brain that's
designed to look for what's wrong to
protect so we protect ourselves to fight
it or to run for it or to freeze right
that's the way our old brain is wired
it's a two million year old brain but
that brain's never going to make you
happy you have to learn to take control
of your focus and if you focus on oh my
God it's never going to work or you
listen to somebody who tells you oh that
you know covet's going to be here
forever and we're never going to have
any freedom again and you focus on that
you can get really depressed as most
people have we've had 100 000 people
overdosed on drugs they have more
depression and more people in a suicidal
mode than we've ever seen in the last
two years because people need a
compelling future you can deal with a
tough today if you've got a compelling
tomorrow and so what I help people do is
design that but once you change your
focus you'll change how you feel focus
and feeling go together we are made to
grow if we don't grow it doesn't matter
how much money you made does how many
people gave you Academy Awards stars on
your chart I mean I get the phone calls
from all these people who you would
think have the greatest life in the
world and then they're calling me
because it's not so great because they
haven't mastered the inner world they're
good at the outer world but this one
this one hasn't been given enough time
or energy they've been so focused out
here and they've done so well out here
not so well in here this is the one you
want to do well on you well here you can
Master the outside world too you can
handle anything so for me it really
comes down to looking at it and saying
okay if you and I are gonna have an
extraordinary level of fulfillment
what's going to make me grow because
that's what's going to make me proud and
to grow you got to face challenges and I
think the biggest problem most people
have
is the biggest problem we have is they
think they shouldn't have problems you
know it's like problems are a sign of
life problems are what make you grow now
you know I'd rather call it a challenge
I'd rather look as a challenge and take
it on as a challenge but you and I both
know I mean I have grown so much in the
last 24 months taking 105 companies some
of which were literally shut down for
you know 12 months keeping them alive
not letting go on my employees figure a
way to turn around figure out adapt I
mean I've developed more skill and
ability to help other people because I
had to manage my own State unbelievably
so I'm going to help other people manage
their state so without the challenge
what I grow so much probably not and
that's why you're successful all
successful people tend to focus on the
future all people that are overwhelmed
tend to focus on the past because you
can't change it but so you say the best
has passed so let it go right so imagine
just for a second somebody's home they
were they're a strong smart person but
they're not feeling strong and smart
because they've been sedentary they're
not using their body and when you don't
use your body you don't have that kind
of energy I don't care who you are right
you're constantly hearing fear coming at
you from all the news that's around
there and so people tend to focus on
What's Missing what they can't control
and they think about the past and will
the future ever be like that but none of
these patterns are going to help you but
you can change all three you can train
yourselves to focus on what you're
grateful for what you have and you can
always build on success that's what
creates momentum you can train yourself
to be able to say Okay if that was
missing that's no problem with it here's
how I'm going to go after it here's how
I I can find the answer if I don't have
the answer and you can train yourself to
enjoy this moment while you're building
your future so those three decisions
alone I could give you a dozen but I'll
give an example I ask people sometimes
in seminars and I've got you know
fifteen thousand thirty thousand people
in a stadium and I'll say how many of
you know someone
who takes antidepressants and they're
still depressed and 90 of people raise
their hand all over the world and so how
could you take antidepressants and still
be depressed well because all they do is
numb you in fact on the side of the box
it says can create Suicidal Thoughts so
numbing you doesn't deal with the
problem as long as you're constantly
focusing on what you don't have or is
missing as long as you're focused on
what you can't control you're going to
find yourself not having what you want
so it's not that difficult but what
people need is they need to shake it up
you can't do these things just be in
your head sitting here at home in your
head because there's not enough energy
the one factor that changes anybody's
life is energy and that's so that's why
I've done my Live Events and that's why
I started doing digital events I didn't
want to do like a webinar I wanted to do
something was a true event so I built a
stadium 20 foot high LED screens I
created Total interact ability so we
have people from 195 countries
participating in real time able to talk
to them connect with them like they are
alive and bring them up large have the
impact so I didn't and let you know
cobit stop me from being able to help
and serve people because people need a
new environment We All Need A New
Perspective without it you're just going
to keep doing the same old stuff and if
you want 2022 to be different than 2021
or 2020 it's not going to come by hoping
it's kind of like coming up with a
vision coming up with a plan building a
few skills so that you stay strong no
matter what they do in the external
environment when I was growing up I grew
up very poor and I'm the oldest of three
and I had to do all the shopping all the
grocery shopping on my bicycle come home
make the meal and I was happy with all
that but then right when you wanted to
be done with your work and go watch
sports or do something great I had to
wash the dishes so I swore someday I
will never do the labor of washing
dishes I will afford a dishwasher I will
find some way to not have to do dishes I
tell you there's a background because
when I told him couldn't be a Furniture
mover he looks down and goes home only
one of their job left
dishwashing now dishwashing in India is
a different labor than you might picture
in your kitchen you're in this ashram
and I report and there's these Nook
solids and yogurts on the floor and
you're standing in your bare feet and
you're taking these filthy dishes coming
across and it's four hours a day for six
or seven days I'm telling you I was so
angry I was so I was mad at myself that
I was there it's mad it was and I was
washing these dishes and upset and plus
I was a vegan and that you know I didn't
like the fact there was milk on the
floor I was judgmental about everything
in the middle of all this stuff after
about an hour of being angry I got tired
of being angry and some part of me
kicked in and goes damn whatever you do
you're the best at it why don't you be
the best damn dishwasher so I started
washing these dishes with a frenzy I'm
like come on guys speed this thing up
and something magical happened
the thing that I thought was most
disgusting and filled with labor and
work became play and I started to laugh
at myself and I thought what an ego jerk
you are to think that you're below
washing some dishes and then I got
beyond my ego and jerk into why not just
enjoy whatever you do and then when you
do all of a sudden it's not work anymore
and that was my great spiritual
breakthrough I eventually did meet with
this Guru and try to straighten him out
but he didn't think very much of an 18
year old killed straight him out he
laughed quite a bit he did talk to my
partners and said I think you guys
should just you know keep teaching what
you're teaching and Fit for Life went on
to be one of the most successful books
in history but I can't claim credit for
that as a part of that little piece but
I will tell you that if you can get over
what if you can get yourself to love to
do the stuff you hate to do then there's
no limit to the success you can have in
your life if you can take the things
that you're afraid you'd have to do to
succeed in your business or to succeed
in your life or uh to succeed in your
relationship or things everybody doesn't
want to do
and the more focused you're on how
you're not going to do that the more
life seems to bring those things up for
you and makes them barriers why is
identity so important for us to shape a
positive powerful identity well first of
all so everybody understands what I mean
by identity is we all have a way of
identifying ourselves we have a way of
labeling ourselves so most of us came up
with our labels based on how we behaved
but really smart people can do stupid
things really nice people can be mean
mean people can be nice and so if you
judge yourself too soon and most
people's identity their labels for
themselves who they think they are has
been based on their past and often many
years ago and so they don't update it so
the the metaphor I give for identity is
like
it's your comfort zone it's not your
goals so if you like if you took a
temperature in the room and said 68
degrees is my comfort zone physically
emotionally financially I want more in
my relationship I want more physically
energy wise I want more financially in
my career but this is what I'm used to
and so what happens people stay in their
comfort zone for the most part and then
let's say something happens and you dip
you're a 68 degree or that's your
mentality and you drop down to 62 61 60
somewhere around 60 or 59 the heaters
kick on and go whoa whoa whoa you're 68
degree what the hell are you doing we've
all experienced that all of a sudden you
go I'm not going to live like this
anymore I'm not going to be in this
relationship I'm not going to be fat
like this how boom and you get this
drive and you start to change but what
most people don't understand
is it happens on the upper end too
meaning let's say you got momentum you
start crushing you start doing even
better than you think you go from 68 to
70 88 you're 98 Degrees financially
emotionally spiritually whatever the
metaphor is and then what happens you're
gonna say Hey you bring us who the hell
do you think you are you're not a 98
degree here
all right get back to 68 and if nothing
else the heaters stop you lose your
drive and that'll drift you back and not
enough the air condition can kick on you
start to kind of sabotage yourself till
you get back to your comfort zone so
unless you expand your identity change
is temperance like when someone says to
me I stopped smoking it's been eight
days and I say why are you counting
so you can tell people how long you
lasted this time like if I went to
somebody and and I said to you hey you
know Louis you want a cigarette you're
not going to say what brand is it you
know no right I'm not a smoker notice
how people I'm not one of those that's
not my identity
identity is the strongest force in the
human personality if you look Lance
Armstrong was a mixed identity now in
the culture
this is a guy that had to win and found
a way to win it so when he was told he
had cancer in his lungs and his brain
and in his testicles and he rides a bike
and he's gonna die his answer was no I'm
a champion I find the way I will find
the answer and he did now unfortunately
he bent the rules around the sport and
it kind of ruined his reputation
obviously but that mentality his
identity is why he survived other people
told they have cancer and they're like
it's over they give up they start
arranging their Affairs and so that
psychological difference is the number
one thing I work with people on Because
unless you expand your identity you're
gonna basically keep where you are you
might improve a little or not you might
go up and down a bit but you're going to
stay within a realm if you're gonna have
an explosive breakthrough to another
level physically mentally financially
spiritually then we got to not only give
you the tools we got to shift that
internal sense of who you really are and
have you find that you are more than
anything that's ever happened to you
that you can handle whatever shows up
even if it's incredibly scary or
uncomfortable it's one of the things
I've got a dozen really important things
to me feeding people's most important to
me providing fresh water I do that in
India for a quarter million people a day
personally I'm going to get that to a
million people in the next few years
it's about infrastructure uh freeing you
know boys and girls women or about 80 of
them I mean there's a new child abducted
every 30 seconds there's six million
people in slavery around the world
children and slavery sexual slavery uh
We've saved about 3 800 just the last
couple of years I've gone on the
operations myself undercover but what I
work with Underground Railroad because
they're former SEAL Team Six cifbi and
we teach the local government what to do
to capture these people so it's not just
Saul save some kids right now but
showing them what to do for the future
um but I'm also you know I'm involved
with so many different things and my
answer is if I think it's it's core to
humanity then I'm interested food is
here is you know I've planted 10 million
trees in the last year and a half you
know I'm more fortunate to have my own
private jet but I'm conscious of that so
it's like how many trees does my whole
lifestyle takes about 3 000 trees I said
but I don't plant you know 10 million I
said screw it'll find 100 million so I
planted 10 million already I'm on course
to the 100 million just like feeding a
billion people so it's it's the things
that matter that's what God Said but I
do things spontaneously I was in San
Francisco and I read in the newspaper
that while I'm there I've never seen
Mark benioff and I see that the the
toughest part of San Francisco is called
the tenderloin district and there's
these nuns there that feed the poorest
of the poor and they're being evicted
and you know it's the richest one of the
richest cities in the world more
billionaires there Tech billionaires
anyway no one's doing anything so I just
I went over and knocked on the door
introduced myself found out who the
person was it was you know dick name
called him up and said look I'm a I'm an
owner too you have the right to evict
anybody but do you really want to be the
hatest man hated the man in San
Francisco I said why don't you let him
stay nine months I'll get them out
within nine months I'll pay you the
additional rent and I did and then you
know the nuns like they're looking for a
place to lease and all of a sudden I get
a call from the Realtree because they're
looking for a place to buy and I call
Bonanza said you got some money I don't
know about God will provide me so I
bought them I bought him a place there
you know and then and my friend Mark
Benny often bought them a home to live
in so you know I do things spontaneously
I love those things things as well but I
mean like the secret to living is giving
I know it sounds corny but I have a
tough time in my life I remember I was
driving on the street in this 1968
Volkswagen I was working so hard and I
was so frustrated things weren't going
the way I thought they should and I was
like what's wrong and then I pulled her
to the side and I stole it today this
written drawer at the secret to living
is giving I started crying because I
lost the giving mode I was just I got
into the business mode and to me like I
said this is a spiritual game if you're
focused on giving if you're doing more
for your client or customer anybody else
you will dominate doesn't matter what
industry you're in and that's what I've
been able to do with you know my 50 plus
companies which really comes down to
anyone can learn anything if it's
important enough to you what makes it
important to me is not just my own life
it's like if I have a problem that my
shoulder my neck whatever and I can
solve it I know that there are millions
of other people can be helped by it so
it's like my drive is not just for me
that wouldn't be enough because it's
easy to meet your own needs it's not
that difficult but if you can find
something that you care about more than
yourself your daughter your son your
family your business your your mission
your community whatever it is that's
really the secret to energy and vitality
and strength and really learning and I
think the other thing is
um complexity is the enemy of execution
one of the things I want to do with
people during this challenge is take
things that seem so complex and make
them so simple so you do it if you have
a business and you got this huge complex
plan you hired a giant consulting firm
they put it all together it never gets
implemented you know it you've been in
your companies why because they make it
so complex and it's somebody else's plan
what I really want to do for people at
this challenge is get it really simple
things you can do right now to change
your life you can go to experience it
that day and then you get momentum day
one day two day three day four and all
of a sudden now what used to be hard to
do is easy to do and I think for anyone
you got to understand anyone can learn
anything if you can just break it down
to its simple core and that's what I try
to do most that's really the essence of
it I used to have all these fancy things
but it's like today I just I just want
to help if I can be helpful to somebody
it gives me tremendous Joy I might my my
hats say you know be a blessing and
you're blessed right that's what these
little hats are that I don't have a
non-religious symbol like a lucky symbol
but it's amazing how lucky you get when
you're working hard to be a blessing and
you know it's amazing what happens for
people so
um my life is already so blessed and and
whatever happens when I'm gone is gone
but while I'm here I want to live fully
and I want to touch as many lives and
help as many people as I can and keep
growing myself I start with the mind and
emotions and uh to me that's not I don't
tell people to believe uh spiritually or
religiously but I believe prayer is a
very useful thing reminding yourself
you're not the center of the universe
and asking for guidance and help and
having things to do that I personally
believe that but not everybody does and
I don't tell people they have to but it
starts there but there's also when you
have a spiritual side of your life
there's a lot less anxiety because you
believe there is something greater than
yourself right and then you do your part
like you said I use I use a similar
metaphor I say it's you know trusting
God and tie up your camels you know that
type of thing right but uh what what
most people don't know is the power of
their mind so there's an entire last two
chapters of the book if no one reads
anything else they say please read those
two chapters because if you do
everything physically well you don't
manage your mind and emotions you'll get
sick how could you not be inspired when
you're seeing people eat again when
you're seeing people be free when you're
you know you're providing surgeries for
you know 100 kids last year that were
blinded who can now see so I get the
juice some of the big things that I get
the juice from the individual things but
it for me it's about impact if you can
have impact in your life is Meaningful
your life life isn't going to be happy
every moment that's [ __ ] but it can
be meaningful every moment you know and
that's your job it's our job to find a
deeper meaning and I think that meaning
comes and the energy of Life comes when
you're not just trying to Serve Yourself
I think unfortunately for so many of us
social media
and technology has started to shape us
instead of us shaping it you know it's
using us and the way it's using us is
it's making us selfish I mean you see
people like banging on their phone like
give it a moment you know it's going to
a satellite give it a second you jerk
you know or you turn around you see
people like expect like everything to be
given to them the moment they push a
button and humans don't work that way I
constantly believe you got to feed your
mind and and challenge your body because
the Mind Body Works together you know
what stops people as we said is fear
well fear is physical you feel in your
throat your gut but if you do something
really physically strong on a regular
basis you develop a new emotional habit
and that emotional habit will get you to
follow through and do things differently
that people won't do it's really not
that complex there are a few habits in
your life that truly could change your
whole life I start every single day with
this process called priming training my
brain to be in a peak State because we
get primed all the time you know people
aren't aware of it but there's a study
that was done not long ago where they
took some people 100 actors they walked
up to 100 people at a park and they
rehearse doing the same thing every time
they reach in their pocket to get their
phone and they or they hand the person a
cup of coffee and then they reach in
their pocket looking they'll say would
you hold this to me for a second to a
full stranger and they grab their phone
look at it type it and they take it back
well thank you so much
the same for everybody but then they
come back 30 minutes later with somebody
with uh and the only difference by the
way is 50 of them have iced coffee uh 50
of them have hot coffee got it now a
person comes by 30 minutes later with a
clipboard gives them twenty dollars and
said if you'll give me literally a
minute and a half of your time to read
this three paragraph story and answer
these two questions this is yours and I
need because people take the 20 bucks
and do it they read the story same story
for everybody
but half the people when they ask them
the main character how would you
describe the qualities of the main
character the character traits the ones
that got iced coffee all say the person
was cold and uncaring 81 say that come
on hot coffee 80 or one percent
difference say the person is warm in
genuine and the only difference is 30
minutes earlier somebody primed them see
you think it's your thoughts much of
your thoughts have been primed by the
environment by the media by what you
read to by your family by your friends
by your culture by your background so
what I do every day is I prime myself
for what I want rather than living the
environment control me I believe in
energy I believe in Inspiration because
inspired in spirit the opposite of that
is kind of dead right certainly I
believe in being inspired but I'm a
strategist and you know you're if you're
inspired and you run east looking for a
sunset I don't give a damn how
enthusiastic you are how positive you
are it's not going to happen right so
I'm a strategist first but I really do
believe that people have got to look at
their life and say as much as I want
great strategy I need a great philosophy
of my life that's going to make me felt
if you're fulfilled like you said you
mentioned earlier if you were with your
friends and you guys weren't succeeding
but you're having a damn good time with
this camaraderie
still worthwhile and you find a way to
succeed eventually but what the hell is
Success it's hitting an expectation
and I always tell people man trade your
expectations for appreciation it's a
whole new world instantly if you can
appreciate this moment if you can't find
ecstasy in this moment in a conversation
with a friend and looking in your wife's
eyes being with your children going on a
run if you can't find XC now I'm here to
tell you more money more people more
love more business more anything is not
going to give you more if you can't do
here now you're not going to do
it so why not do it now and have a rich
life right now I tell people
money that's one thing like having
Financial abundance there's skills
that's a science but wealth it's a
decision it's like you can be wealthy
right now I I live in Fiji good portion
of the time there are these villagers
there they're the richest people I know
they're happy they laugh they love they
don't give a damn about the economics
other people say they're poor when I
first went there I was trying to do
things for them they're like what are
you talking about I'm so happy wealthy
people come over from the United States
and they go travel around and try to
figure out what to do and they're going
to spend nine you know years to do this
and this and this so they can finally
sit down and be happy and the gene guy
goes why don't you sit on the beach
right now dude and experience it why
spend the nine years
why not happen now that's my invitation
emotion is in if we get the right
emotion we can get ourselves to do
anything we can get through it if you're
a creative enough playful enough fun
enough can you get through to anybody
yes or no if you don't have the money
but you're created but term enough you
find the way so this is the ultimate
resource but this is not the story that
people tell us right the story people
tell us is a bunch of different stories
they tell us we don't have the resources
But ultimately if you take a look here
flip it up if you would
they say what are all the reasons they
have in common we said that next one
please he's broken my pattern
thank you
but I appreciated the energy I'll tell
you that
what determines your resources we said
decision shape Destiny which is my focus
here if decision shape Destiny what
determines it is three decisions what
are you going to focus on right now you
have to decide what you're going to
focus on in the second consciously or
unconsciously the minute you decide to
focus on something you got to give it a
meaning
and whatever that meaning is produces
emotion is this the end or the beginning
is God punishing me or rewarding me or
is this the role of the dice an emotion
then creates what we're going to do or
the action so think about your own life
the decisions that have shaped your
destiny and that sounds really heavy but
in the last five or ten years 15 years
have there been some decisions you've
made that if you've made a different
decision your life would be completely
different
how many can think of one honestly
Better or Worse say I
so the bottom line is maybe it was where
to go to work and you met the love of
your life there maybe it was a career
decision I know the Google Geniuses I
saw here I mean I understand that their
decision was to sell their technology at
first what if they made that decision
versus to build their own culture how
would the world be different how would
their lives be different their impact
the history of our world is these
decisions when a woman stands up and
says no I won't go to the back of the
bus
she doesn't just affect her life that
decision shaped our culture or someone
standing in front of a tank or being in
a position like Lance Armstrong and
someone says to you you've got
testicular cancer that's pretty tough
for any male especially if you ride a
bike
you got in your brain you got in your
lungs but what was his decision what to
focus on different than most people what
did it mean it wasn't the end it was the
beginning what am I going to do he goes
off and wins seven championships he
never once once before the cancer
because he got emotional Fitness
psychological strength that's the
difference in human beings that I've
seen of the three million have been
around because that's about my lab I've
had three million people from 80
different countries that I've had a
chance to interact with over the last 29
years and after a while patterns become
obvious you see that South America and
Africa maybe connect in a certain way
right other people say oh that sounds
ridiculous it's simple so what shape
Lance what shapes you two invisible
forces very quickly one state
we all have had time so if you had a
time you did something and after you did
you thought to yourself I can't believe
I said that I can't believe I did that
that was so stupid who's been there say
aye
have you ever done something after you
do
it with me
all right it wasn't your ability it was
your state I showed people to change
that quickly but what I want to finish
with quickly here is you're a model of
the world is what shapes you long term
your model of the world is the filter
that's what's shaping us that's what
makes people make decisions we want to
influence somebody we got to know what
already influences them and it's made
about three parts I believe First what's
your target what are you after which I
believe it's not your desires you can
get your desires and goals how many of
you got a goal is iron thought is this
all there is how many been there say I
so it's needs we have I believe there's
six human needs second once you know
what the target that's driving you is
and you uncover it for the truth you
don't form it you uncover it then you
find out what's your map what's the
belief systems that are telling you how
to get those needs some people think a
way to get those needs is destroy the
world some people is to build something
create something love someone
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see my recent interview with
Tony Robbins check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there there is a regenerative Revolution
that's happening in medicine right now
in Precision medicine billionaires know
about it but the average person doesn't
would push me over the edge recently is
I had some experiences that really hit
me hard